et si on sautait dans un de ces bateaux
et qu'on s'en allait loin ça me plaît
tu as de la visite
loin loin
très loin d'ici
montrez-moi vos
chanceux j'ai plein d'autres filles
j'étais en train de penser à ma mère
elle était comment
très belle
malheureuse
c'est qui cette fille c'est la plus
belle de toutes les filles de l'Ouest il
faut que je la rencontre
[Musique]
en fait j'étais pas
tu es pas venu pour ça
vous allez m'épouser
et m'emmener loin d'ici me donner une
vie respectable
[Musique]
ne vous laissez point aller à de telles
pensées
je vous présente
vous n'aviez pas choisi cette villa
choisir une nouvelle
[Musique]
elle ne t'aime pas et tu utilises tu
n'as pas la moindre idée de qui est
pensé que je vais devenir quelqu'un que
je ne suis pas
là c'est la maison
c'est vous qui voyez